et plusieurs moments politiques
marquants dans la dernière année c'est
maintenant l'heure des bilans des
bulletins et je me disais ils sont tous
les trois avec nous bonsoir 3 quel
plaisir de vous avoir sur ce plateau on
pense pas que m alors on va faire un
retour sur les six derniers mois ce qui
vous a marqué on va le faire bien sûr
par catégories comme on le fait toujours
alors on commence avec ce qui vous a le
plus surpris vous tasha à quoi est-ce
que vous vous attendiez pas du tout je
m'attendais pas à l'élection du
gouvernement npd en alberta la montée de
retournac et c'est quelque chose qui
était une surprise pour beaucoup de gens
pour les conservateurs en particulier
mais c'était surprenant parce qu'on
pense ce jour que l'alberta c'est une
province assez conservatrice mais c'est
unis les conservateurs progressistes
conservateurs ou le wildrose qu'il a
remporté c'est limpide et alors ça
c'était pour moi la grande soeur
michelle vous exactement c'est
exactement ce que j'ai ressenti à voir
si je suis retenu un tremblement tout
l'intérêt de la chose et que ce
changement de paradigme là pourraient
être contagieux c'est vraiment son
intérêt je pense autre pour les
albertains pour nous qui sommes un peu
loin ceux de savoir est-ce que ça va
déteindre sur le reste du pays
l'automne prochain gens qui sont dit ça
peut se faire en alberta ça peut amener
ailleurs aussi daniel maintenant est
absolument d'accord avec mes deux
collègues
sauf que comme celle du depuis quelques
temps et même avant l'élection dans
l'âme de retiennent la perte en eau sans
que le npd est en train de remonter la
côte est qu'il m'offre un climat une
tendance très lourde favorable aux
impayés depuis quatre ou cinq mois
j'avais des élections demain pas certain
que thomas mulcair ne dégagerait pas sa
ville à l'histoire du canada il ya
toujours un retour de la pendule après
des années des fans des cas les années
trudeau après des années trudeau et des
animaux revenait des années chrétiens et
puis des années à peu on y dit pour un
retour de la pendule vers de santé
peut-être que cette fois ya 60 ans les
libéraux mme un peu plus à gauche
alors maintenant deuxième catégorie le
coup de maître c'est à dire le meilleur
geste politique dix ans selon vous parce
qu'on voulait les gestes des politiques
qui ont fait une différence alors michel
je commence à laisser le retour de
gilles duceppe qui pourrait faire la
différence et c'est vraiment ça aussi
c'est une surprise mais quelques mois de
l'élection changé le chef comme ça c'est
pas banal ça pour elle ou un coup d'épée
dans l'eau
sa lèvre pas les gens vont dire c'est
fini l'importance est batteur ou alors
il réussit à remonter le bloc et là ça
peut changer le résultat de l'élection
dans tout le pays est privé le npd d'un
gouvernement qui est outre hama il
aurait toutes les chances de former moi
c'est pas des politiciens comme tel moi
ce qui m'a le plus frappé cette année ce
sont des décisions de la cour suprême et
des dizaines très importante sur le
sénat sur la prostitution rumeurs sur la
loi et l'ordre etc
des décisions qui étaient très
importantes pour les canadiens général
parce que on dit souvent il faut pas que
la cour suprême remplacent les
politiciens sa hutte rend des décisions
sauf que quand les politiciens sont pas
capables de prendre une décision
ou quand il ya une espèce de dérive
idéologique comme si le cob normand ap
on est tous très content qu'à la fin de
journée la cour suprême dise non non non
c'est comme ça qu'ils adressent pas
intéressant vous tâche a énormément de
coups de mecs j'ai vu sauf que je vais
bons gestes positifs mais déjà ce qu'ils
ont on non mais moi ce que je ce qui
m'impressionne le plus c'est que
effectivement les conservateurs et le
npd tous les deux on monte dans les
sondages et maintenant les parties sont
quasiment à l'égalité les libéraux ont
beaucoup chuté
c'était plus que l'inde et des
conservateurs ont vraiment réussi à
rejoindre leur base respecter de façon
consistante depuis octobre dernier
finalement et de cette façon là je pense
ont réussi à regrimper alors c'est plus
par des coups de maître mais du travail
ardu
on n'est pas toujours d'accord avec ce
qu'ils ont fait mais je pense qu'ils ont
rejoint leurs électeurs bon troisième
catégorie a toujours des gaffes des
erreurs pendant une session
parlementaire ne tirez pas parfois ça
serait pas alors quand on pense au pire
geste politique
daniel qu'est ce que vous avez
celui de cv l'armée un geste qu'il n'a
pas posé ses grands peut décider cette
année en 2015 que le sait là ça n'allait
nulle part qu'il ne s'en préoccupait
plus qui se foutait du procès le fait
qu'il n'est pas remplacé les 20 postes
vacants au sénat
il réalise que cet institut sera là et
est complètement décrié méprisé par
presque toute la population
absolument rien qui peut faire aucune
façon de la réforme et parce que c'est
trop compliqué
bref après un 10 mois le sénat je veux
plus en entendre parler et la question
qu'on se pose en ce moment non seulement
van tinh nommer des sénateurs pour
remplacer les vins mais qui voudra aller
siéger au pénal en tournée avec les
nouveaux cas qu'on a vu aujourd'hui
oui mais tâche avait proposé un
référendum la mer oui bon alors daniel
michel disdier vraiment le pire j'ai
celui qui m'a déplu à fait le plus peur
je pense enfin que ça elle va avoir de
grosses conséquences et la destruction
de la partie québécoise du registre des
armes à feu gîte avec certaines
décisions
meskine à courte vue injurieuse pour les
victimes de polytechnique et surtout pas
pro surtout et aussi peu respectueuse du
fédéralisme normalement il y en a
certains principes de courtoisie qui
doit s'opérer et la salle verrier aux
autres provinces enverriez au canada de
conserver cette partie là de registre et
je trouvais que monsieur monsieur
rapport à mai et et chips pas passer les
gains qu'on doit absolument train et
j'ai pas aimé ça moi c'était la fameuse
conférence de presse où justin trudeau a
ramené ou a amené y va du parti
conservateur aux libéraux c'était un
moment un pire le pire je dis parce que
j'ai beaucoup d'amis dans le parti
libéral croyez le ou non qui ont été
vraiment vraiment flatté vraiment
attaché à cause de ça il n'a pas réussi
ils pensé avoir un coup mettre justement
de d'avoir une conservatrice dans à ses
côtes
la convertir quoi mais ça réussit à
faire l'opposé et je pensais beaucoup de
gens il a perdu beaucoup de plumes non
seulement à l'extérieur sont partis mais
même à l'intérieur
bon on a souvent l'impression qu'un
sujet peu après quand on fait le bilan
un peu politique à la fin d'une année
qu'il ya des sujets qu'on doit on n'a
pas assez parlé
le on a appelé ça le grand oublié alors
tâche à vous moi c'est l'environnement
parce que je pense au fédéral en tout
cas dans les provinces on en parle on
sait que le québec l'ontario se sont
rapprochés sur la question des marchés
de carbone par exemple mais aussi qu'au
fédéral demeure le dossier perdu le
dossier qu'on ne veut pas s'en occuper
et je pense est une erreur parce que ce
qu'on a vu avec les pipelines
c'est une influence directe du fait que
le gouvernement n'ait pas vu comme un
acteur environnementale sérieux
messieurs obama ne pourrait jamais
approuvé la frite hingis ton alors pour
moi c'est vraiment l'échec
effectivement et de dossiers mais non
quand ça va être un sujet important on
en a parlé tout à l'heure avant la
conférence de demain lee michel si
l'aide internationale du canada
cantonales l'international on reparle de
sécurité où on parle de poutine mais on
parle rarement de la baisse la
diminution de l'aide internationale du
canada et plus plus généralement de de
la disparition de son rôle humanitaire
parce qu'il n'y a pas simplement les
budgets dave qui diminue beaucoup on a
vu un rapport du directeur parlementaire
du budget qui indiquait que ça va être
des centres baissé de 23% 7,6 toujours
en proportion de plus en plus petit du
pib d'année en année mais il ya aussi
l'accueil aux réfugiés les critères sont
plus en plus compliqué le canada en
accueil de moins en moins et il n'y a
aucune empathie on le voit encore
aujourd'hui l'avait cryer badaoui on
voit que au québec ça bouge mais ottawa
on a envoyé des signaux ya rien qui se
fait alors tout le tout se retrouveront
par où passent les expulsions qui s'en
viennent
les haïtiens daniel moi je prend le
relais de michel arcens l'immigration on
a parlé
toujours pour lui enfin des mauvaises
raisons peut-être pas les bonnes raisons
on parle beaucoup de tchadors de burqa
et tout ça mais il ya un problème majeur
aujourd'hui les nations unies ont publié
des données il ya 60 millions de
réfugiés l'an passé seulement travers le
monde il ya une douzaine de pays sur ce
total est la syrie à tête où les gens ne
veulent plus vivre ce que ça veut dire
c'est que tôt ou tard les grands pays
industrialisés
le canada dans ce groupe vont devoir
ouvrir leurs portes largement ces gens
ne peuvent pas regarder faire ce qui se
passe 10 rebonds l'italie s'en occupe
là là là où gruissan de cuves où la
serbie s'en occupe
à un moment donné ça va exploser et ça
va exploser très fort et pas certains
comme michel dit que le canada est prêt
à jouer le jeu à ce niveau là c'est un
vraiment un problème la hongrie qui veut
et j'ai un mur entre la hongrie et la
serbie bon michel si on avait à vous
demander la déception de l'année a pour
moi c'est la fin de course de bernad bon
de rêver tout le monde était assez
certains que monsieur péladeau gagnerait
bon mais là monsieur dream elle avait
peur de finir troisième et est encore là
qu'ils soient qu'ils soient partis bon
si t'as pas glorieux mais enfin ce n'est
pas la fin du monde mais qui sera lié à
monsieur péladeau
après avoir dit que c'est un mirage
qu'il fallait pas lui donner un chèque
en blanc
je pense qu'il aurait pu simplement se
retirer de la course et faire comme ceux
de jean françois lisée dire écoutez je
n'ai plus personne dira c'est à ses
partisans depuis qu'il voulait mais pas
de se rallier à ce qu'il présentait
comme un énorme problème il part alors
seul je peux retrouver sa forme et s'il
n'ya pas essayer de rallier le parti en
fait pour la suite
il voulait éviter de diviser mais y
était pas pour éviter d'user ses obligés
de se rallier à monsieur péladeau
il était simplement il peut simplement
ça et c'est de l'attaqué vous n'avez pas
aimé ça j'avais donné à des d'ailleurs
avoué les faits
daniel justin trudeau pour plusieurs
raisons mais ont laissé qu'international
surtout en début d'année justin trudeau
était l'alternative la seule aux
consommateurs de six venant peut
justement de care est à 20% dans les
sondages étaient pas dans le temps le
décor il ya eu la déclaration sur le
marathon de boston andrew c des causes
sociales c'est pas le terrorisme il ya
eu la déclaration sur les avions de
chasse en dix ans après s'amuse avec ses
joueurs en syrie et il ya eu surtout je
pense que c'est la plus grosse erreur
qui l'a fait l'appui des libéraux au
projet de loi c 51
celui qui donne trop de pouvoirs à la
grc et le scrs pour combattre le
terrorisme et à partir de ce moment là
ça s'est effondré et ça c'était faudrait
à une vitesse vertigineuse de semaine en
semaine de sondage en sondage ils
s'écrasent comment peut-il remonter sept
contre les libéraux autour de lui
s'arrache les cheveux d'un avion qui
s'écrase mais en tout cas moi pour la
déception
l'ado est sacrée mais je ne suis pas un
amour avec le parti québécois on sait ça
mais pour ceux ci j'étais impliqué je
serais déçu parce que effectivement les
faits péladeau ne s'est pas manifestée
lors des partielles il mais a toujours
des problèmes concernant c'est si les
intérêts personnels qui sont en conflit
ont dit avec ses intérêts politiques
c'est quelque chose je pense on
attendait un peu plus et on n'a pas vu
ça adaptées peut-être ça va changer mais
pour moi c'était pas c'était pas le
phénomène ne repique pkp qu'on pensait
qu'ils sont d'accord avec ça monsieur
péladeau a finalement ben qu'oui où tout
le monde savait qui était programmé mais
depuis qu'il est là je trouve qu'ils
fassent au mieux que ce qu'on aurait pu
penser à large ne le trouve pas de
savoir se débarrasser juste un bon alors
les élections fédérales à l'horizon à
l'automne tous les chefs doivent
convaincre les électeurs de voter pour
eux qui a le plus gros défi l'on
voudrait
un thomas mulcair c'est toujours
difficile quand vous êtes en tête et
quand vous arrivez en tête un peu
trouvent et à quatre mois des élections
le npd s'est effondré souvent dans le
passé rappelez-vous aile droite dante a
été premier dans les sondages dans les
années moroni ça n'a pas duré
le plus gros défi en ce moment deux
marqueurs ça va te faire face à la
mitraille qui la veille de lui tomber
sur la tête
on va on va on va voir des publicités
très négatif sur lui pour le traiter de
communiste socialiste maxime exactement
et ça va être très difficile
les autres questions vont se poser ce
qu'ils ont assez d'argent pour faire une
grosse campagne comme des conservateurs
qui eux au trésor incroyable est-ce
qu'ils ont une organisation assez solide
surtout québec pour garder les acquis un
gros défi pour monsieur matière d'achats
mois ces messieurs du sec le nouveau
juré joueurs parce que bon premièrement
il a surpris beaucoup de gens mais
deuxième à son parti son parti n'a pas
beaucoup d'argent sont partis à ce
manque de sièges
ou est-ce qu'il va aller avec ça comment
ça va convaincre se plaint déjà du
traitement qui reçoit des médians et
l'intérêt que le manque d'intérêt à sa
candidature
alors pour moi c'est lui qui a le plus
grand le plus grand défi à convaincre
les électeurs pourquoi choisir le bloc
québécois michel voici monsieur trudeau
parce que c'est trudeau a commis une
erreur fait une faute qui est à mon sens
c'est impardonnable c'est qu'on cas où
il ya beaucoup d'espoir qui sont mises
en vous et que vous les décevez c'est
extrêmement difficile par la suite de
regagner la confiance des gens et
monsieur trudeau a vraiment
démontrer avec application depuis deux
ans que ce qu'on pensait qu'il était il
ne l'est pas et ça va être extrêmement
difficile pour lui de le redevenir
mais il ya quand même présenté là des
bons coups j'avais trouvé que ça sonne
allocations familiales universelles et
est beaucoup plus intéressante que ce
que monsieur harper aux frais ça c'est
un bon coup mais depuis ce temps là
honnêtement je pense pas que on va
vraiment se passionner pour les modèles
la modification du mode de scrutin
non l élection obligatoires ça ressemble
à des d espèce de truc qui sont là pour
masquer dans le fond l'absence de fonds
c'est intéressant il ya des mesures très
intéressante attendait défend vol le
jour tu vois qu'ils vont vous dirai ce
que je veux moyens au système
proportionnel ou est ce que je suis au
change c'est un bon en avant le mot à
retenir cette année d'achat mais pour
moi le mot qu'on entend tout le temps
c'est austérité
je suis pas surprise parce que c'est le
bo qui a défini la politique québécoise
de l'année dernière à la fois à
l'assemblée nationale dans l'affût dans
les débats sociaux c'est quoi des expos
c'est quoi le but de l'état et pour moi
c'est un débat intéressant c'est moins
intéressant parce que ça a vraiment fait
un débat de société cependant si le
gouvernement leur rigueur budgétaire
l'an passé j'en avais très beau
ostentatoire bouchaoui
comme le temps passe vite et cambran ça
sent loin ce qui voit ses parts à toi
j'avais beaucoup ce mot avait découvert
à ce moment là j'ai aussi austérité ce
qui fascine nathan rad en ce moment
c'est que des deux côtés du débat il ya
depuis quelques mois des gens très
brillants des économistes raid rien de
réputation internationale des très bons
au québec aussi important qu'il dise des
choses très intéressantes comme quoi la
vérité ça fonctionne pas au pis c'est
pas très géniale et donc qui vous
démontre aussi très clairement que oui
il faut une austérité
on peut pour vivre au dessus de nos
moyens un moment donné faut finir par
payer
alors j'aime beaucoup de mots les met
d'accord c'est moi c'est pas le mot de
l'année célèbre cité de la musique
version une connerie comme cela est
vraiment ça dépasse l'année je ne peux
pas croire que les conservateurs vont
laisser monsieur là ça ne prendre sa
retraite c'est moi c'est une en compte
tenu du bon alors on a dépassé un peu
notre temps mais en quelques secondes
quel joueur allait surveiller parce que
là vous allez prendre vos vacances je
surveillais je le dis une chose est sûre
pour moi le soleil de tien juste sauvé
thomas snooker parce que justement c'est
le 5 points de hausse et c'est sur lui
que tout le monde
huit membres moi je veux sortir de ce
cadre de l'élection et je vais
surveiller jean martin aussant des
prochains mois oui l'annoncé ni plus ni
moins qui rentre alors là j'ai vraiment
hâte de voir comment il va se réinsérer
dans le jeu politique
et s'il retourne au pq à quelles
conditions et qu'est ce que monsieur
péladeau est prêt à lui accorder pour le
ramener au bercail
alors on va vous souhaiter un bon été
peut-être dix années écourtées par
élection on verra ce temps mais merci
beaucoup d'avoir été là toute l'année
toujours fidèle au poste merci
au mois d'août au mois de septembre